ههه
وسط اجواء يسودها الارتياح وروح العائله
الواحده انهى المنتخب المغربي ممثل الكره
العربيه والافريقيه استعداداته للمباراه
التاريخيه التي ستجمعه بالمنتخب الفرنسي
حامل لقب النسخه الماضيه في نصف نهائي كاس
العالم قطر 2022
التاهل تاريخي على حساب البرتغال في ربوع
النهائي اعطى جرعه معنويه لاسود الاطلس
ولو ان المهمه هذه المره ستكون اكثر صعوبه
امام رفاقي كليان مبابي لكن المدرب وليد
الركراكي لا يرى سقفا لطموحات الاسود في
هذا المونديال
هذه العقليه قد تعتقدون انني مجنون لكن
انا نريد الوصول الى نهائي كاس العالم
وانا لا اقول هذا فقط نريد ان نذهب الى
ابعد من ذلك
تمام فان لاعبي فريق مستعدون لتقديم افضل
ما عندهم لتحقيق المفاجاه كما فعلنا ضد
بلجيكا وكرواتيا واسبانيا والبرتغال
الحصه التدريبيه الاخيره للمنتخب المغربي
في ملعب نادي الدحيل شهدت غياب المدافع
نايف اجرد الذي لم يشارك في مواجهه
البرتغال بعد اصابته خلال لقاء اسبانيا في
ثمن النهائي وفي حال عدم جاهزيه اجرد فمن
المتوقع ان يعيد الركراكي الاعتماد على
جواد الياميق الذي عوضه في تشكيل الاساسي
في لقاء البرتغال من جهه اخرى تدرب كل من
قائد اسود الاطلس
اضافه الى الثلاثي مزراوي وحكيم ومصيري
بشكل انفرادي
حتى وان كان الخصم هذه المره فرنسا حامله
تلقب نسخه السابقه فان المدرب وليد
الرجراجي رسخ قاعده لدى لاعبي خلال
الادوار السابقه مفادها نحن الاسود وخلفنا
الملايين لا نهب احدا وسنواصل المغامره
حتى الرمق الاخير حمزه الراضي الجزيره
الدوحه